depuis hier ils sont une trentaine à
bloquer l'entrée de leur entreprise
certains ont même passé la nuit ici des
salariés en colère est inquiet car leur
société peine à verser les salaires la
direction vient d'annoncer aujourd'hui
que l'intégralité du mois de janvier
sera payé mais elle n'a pas apporté de
précision pour les prochaines semaines
je lui ai demandé qu en face un courrier
comme quoi on aurait une garantie pour
les salaires du mois de mars à la
capable 2010 akka pas donc on n'a aucune
garantie
on a besoin de cet argent quand même on
a besoin de deux pas de manger deux pays
de factures deux aspects vont ils vont
pas nous nous échelonnés au bout d'un
moment quand les factures y tombe tombe
si l argent c'est bien ce n'est pas
l'argent mais on fait quoi une situation
d'autant difficile que les salariés sont
au chômage partiel depuis le 19 décembre
dernier et ne touche donc que 70 % de
leur salaire
l'entreprise doit faire face à des
problèmes de trésorerie elle tourne au
ralenti pour l'instant impossible de
savoir quand l'activité reprendra
normalement on attend de l'argent des
capitaux qui leur est rentré dans le
dans le consortium selni sourdillon
parce qu'on a plusieurs filiales et
placement n'a rien donc voilà et si on
n'a rien on peut pas acheter de matières
premières donc ce qui fait que eba
il n'y a plus rien les ateliers on peut
on peut rire produire actuellement rien
du tout voilà de son côté la direction
se montre optimiste elle assure que
l'actionnaire croit en l'avenir de
l'entreprise et souhaite réinjecter de
l'argent
cela permettrait à terme le redémarrage
du site